la course aura été de courte durée
richissounac a rapidement reçu la pluie
de la moitié des députés conservateurs
seuls sur la ligne de départ c'est lui
qui dirigera le parti et donc le pays et
c'est privé c'est le plus grand honneur
de ma vie dit-il
issu d'une famille d'origine indienne
son arrivée au pouvoir marque une
première à darning Street mais le
nouveau dirigeant achète 42 ans c'est
bien qu'il n'a pas le temps de célébrer
ayant été kingdom is
country
fait face à des difficultés économiques
majeures lancent l'ancien ministre des
Finances l'inflation dépasse les 10%,
les marchés ont été secoués par le plan
fiscal annoncé par sa prédécesseur le
mois dernier
c'était d'ailleurs une grande différence
dans la course qui l'avait opposé à
l'esturasse au cours de l'été Vichy
Sonac était très critique des baisses
d'impôts promise par son adversaire
parmi ces autres défis l'unité de son
parti les conservateurs ont vu trois
chefs se succéder en quelques mois
seulement l'ancien Premier ministre
Boris Johnson qui a tenté sans succès un
retour à l'avant-plan a toujours ses
partisans dans le passé Vichy sunnaki
lui ont connu d'importants différents
politique dans son pays le prochain
Premier ministre doit aussi regagner la
confiance des électeurs il y a d'abord
son image personnelle Richie sunac dans
la fortune familiale dépasse les 700
millions de livres sterling et depuis
longtemps accusé par ses adversaires
d'être déconnecté de la réalité
le nouveau chef doit aussi composé avec
des sondages qui sont dévastateurs pour
les conservateurs l'opposition
travailler les devants avec parfois plus
de 35 points
d'opposition la première ministre
écossaise exige la tenue d'un scrutin
anticipé puisque pour le choix de ce
premier ministre seuls les députés
conservateurs ont été consultés devant
son cocus wishi sunac aurait rejeté
cette option sans revirement majeur il
faudra attendre 2024 voir le début 2025
avant les prochaines élections
d'ici là les conservateurs souhaitent
enfin un peu de stabilité cinq premiers
ministres de ce parti se sont succédé au
10 darning Street au cours des 12
dernières années alors que le chat
officiel de la résidence Larry lui n'a
pas bougé
c'est rafale Bouvier au clair
Radio-Canada à Paris